what's going on guys this is rob and the
trailer for the new hawkeye show just
launched which as we know is going to
feature kate bishop and so i figured we
would make a video kate bishop explained
now here's the thing kate bishop first
appeared in young avengers vol 1 issue
number one in april 2005 and she was
created by alan heinberg and jim chung
who's probably one of the most fantastic
artists in the history of comics now
there's a couple things that we have to
discuss here right the first one is who
the young avengers are why they matter
and the second is why kate bishop was
created in the first place so the young
avengers was marvel's attempt to kind of
expand the avengers roster and then
change it at the same time one of the
things we've talked about before we
don't really need to to go in depth and
rehash it here is that in the aftermath
of the 90s when marvel went bankrupt a
guy named joe casada came in as the new
editor-in-chief and basically started
implementing a whole bunch of changes in
the sense that marvel seemed to have
lost its way over the course of the mid
to late 1990s and even in casada's eyes
going back into the 80s and the desire
was kind of to reset marvel so to speak
and so that's why peter parker's
marriage to mary jane watson was
nullified that's why the events of house
of m happened where the mutant
population was reduced from millions
down to like 198 and that's the reason
why avengers disassembled took place now
the idea of avengers disassembled was
the first step in reworking the avengers
roster as a whole avengers disassembled
as most of you guys know is when the
scarlet witch launched her attack
against the avengers it was the events
that led into house of m but the idea
here was that tony stark was basically
manipulated by the scarlet witch into
appearing drunk in front of the united
nations and quite literally lambasting
uh foreign leaders right so he just he
went full on rudy giuliani and the
result of this is that stark industries
value just plummeted and because of that
stark couldn't bankroll the avengers
anymore and so this basically led to the
avengers disbanding now in the aftermath
of this marvel did two major things the
first thing they did is that they
basically followed up with the new
avengers which was essentially a new
avengers team with a new roster but the
second thing they did is they created
the young avengers now the young
avengers were initially an unsanctioned
team right which is to say it was a
bunch of teenagers that had basically
come together and started operating as
superheroes the idea of kate bishop goes
back a little bit further but truth to
tell it was only in young avengers
number one that she suddenly appears and
we didn't really know anything about her
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to kind of sidetrack for a second
and we're going to focus on all new
hawkeye which was basically the
recreation of kate bishop or at least
the the backstory of kate bishop as it
was fully given to us right because up
until the launch of that solo series all
we had was young avengers special number
one which was really more of like a
superhero roll call right that's really
all it was right everybody who's part of
the young adventures raise your hands
here's a brief little bio about them and
that was basically it the idea behind
kate bishop is that unlike somebody like
hawkeye or something like that she
didn't really end up becoming the person
that she was or becoming an avenger
because she was duped into operating
alongside black widow who was like a
criminal at the time and then eventually
realized what was going on and became a
good guy instead kay bishop was born to
a pretty wealthy family and her father
was a man that she'd idolized now the
relationship with the rest of her family
was very tenuous and very very strained
in fact the relationship with her mother
was virtually non-existent but
ultimately cadence of learning the
family's money and their wealth was
basically built on in a lot of ways
criminal acts following that she kind of
becomes disillusioned with the entire
idea of her family as a whole and
basically strikes out to kind of make
her own way in the world now one of the
big similarities that was given to us
with kate bishop and the original
hawkeye clint barton is that she's very
very stubborn and she's very very
independent and in fact that's something
that a lot of young women really latched
on to with the character of kate bishop
it's what they enjoyed right the fact
that she would rather struggle and do it
on her own than ask somebody for help
because the lessons she'll learn in
trying on her own and failing far
outweigh the benefits she'll gain by
asking somebody else for help and
ultimately succeeding the result of this
is that kate bishop had actually bumped
into hawkeye now for the most part the
idea between her and clint barton being
having a kind of father-daughter
relationship wasn't really a major focal
point at this point in time it was more
of the fact that she had come across
clint barton and started to idolize
clint barton and really modeled herself
after him but even then her role as a
superhero hadn't quite been fleshed out
a lot of this didn't really come to
fruition until you got to the young
avengers special and what you actually
ended up learning is that in central
park kate bishop was a victim of sexual
assault and the result of this is that
following that while she did go through
a very tumultuous time period in her
life following this particular ordeal
that she came out of it with this
exceedingly high desire to ensure that
she would be able to survive anything
like that again and so while the
motivation behind her becoming something
that was comparable to clint barton was
different than what clint barton
initially went through the result was
that in a lot of ways she was very
similar now i won't say she was as good
as clint barton because truth to tell i
never really felt like kate bishop was
as capable as clint barton was but she
was exceedingly exceptional now a lot of
this origin story was covered again in
an all new hawkeye and young avengers
special number one and so what it does
is it bookends into young avengers
itself now at the time that kate bishop
was introduced to marvel comics the big
question people had is why does it
matter like why are they doing this
because initially over the course of
young avengers in the first story arc
right in the the sidekick story arc you
didn't really know what role she was
going to play and in fact when you
actually saw her becoming part of the
young avengers she was kind of a
hodgepodge of different people she was
using the guardsman sword she was using
the staves of mockingbird as well as
mockingbird's mask she was using these
different aspects of different
characters across the avengers landscape
and really didn't have a full
fleshed-out identity it wasn't until you
got to the end of young avengers that
she fully became what was in effect the
new version of hawkeye now there was an
old interview that was done back in 2006
where wizard magazine had interviewed
alan heinberg and they'd asked him why
create a new k bishop why not just
recreate clint barton and the answer to
this was because clint barton was
largely a character who was deemed to be
irrelevant by the time the events of
house of m came around and truth to tell
he was right i don't i can't really
imagine very many people who would have
cited or would have kind of stood up and
said it's ridiculous that marvel's
replacing clinton barton with kate
bishop right they just need to make her
a whole different character clint barton
needs to stay nobody was really an
advocate of hawkeye hawkeye had been a
largely irrelevant character for decades
and so it made perfect sense that if
marvel was going to legitimately kill
anybody off they would kill off hawkeye
right he's like one of the guys that
nobody would really miss now in all
honesty if we're if we're being truthful
here the reason why kate bishop sort of
fell to the wayside we'll talk more
about that here in a little while but
the reason why she kind of fell to the
wayside and clint barton sort of
returned back to being a prominent
character was because of the mcu right
because jeremy renner was cast as clint
barton and he became a mainstay and we
knew he was going to be in the avengers
film so if anything if for no other
reason than to sell comics marvel had to
basically bring clint martin back and
make him a mainstay of marvel comics but
by all standards of measurement at the
time young avengers was launched clint
barton while he was supposed to come
back was never supposed to go back to
being a major focal point as far as the
hawkeye mythos went that was all
supposed to go to to kate bishop now in
these early stories because the young
avengers were an unsanctioned team that
were not you know officially recognized
by the avengers themselves they just
kind of did their own thing the first
question is why did they exist well the
answer to this was given to us in the
sidekick storyline when we ended up
learning that somewhere along the line
the vision had developed what was in
effect a series of protocols so that if
the avengers were destroyed or disbanded
then a new generation would be tapped to
become the avengers in their place now
only three of them were really picked
here hulkling patriot and wiccan the
other three just kind of showed up
particularly kate bishop and cassie lang
now the initial idea here as far as kate
bishop and cassie lang felt was that
like all the guys were being sexist
because they wouldn't let him join
eventually they were like no it's simply
that you were not picked by the vision
to be one of the new avengers team or
the young avengers team so that's why we
can't let you guys join but the
situation in the first few young
avengers stories unfolded in such a way
to where kate bishop proved herself to
be a valuable member of the team and
this particularly fell in relation to
the events surrounding iron lad and king
the conqueror now for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with iron lad he's
basically kang when he was a teenager
and the idea is that in the 30th century
when kang was like a full-on adult and
would go on to become this kind of
multiversal conqueror that we're
familiar with he visited his younger
self to show him what he would end up
becoming his younger self rejected the
idea that he would become king the
conqueror so he fled to the present day
to become part of the young avengers and
to serve as a superhero to defy the idea
that he would ultimately end up becoming
a villain the way this all played out in
the first young event really the first
couple young avengers story arcs is that
if iron lad did not become kang reality
itself would begin to fall apart and
that's why the stories of iron lad
largely focus on the idea that he
ultimately surrendered himself to kang
and then they went to the future and he
was destined to become his future self
right things had to play out that way if
they didn't the whole timeline would
fall apart right and the reason is
because if iron lad never becomes kang
kang doesn't exist if kang doesn't exist
kang never meets the avengers at those
particular points in time and because of
that the universe can't follow its
present course therefore the universe
would simply cease to exist right just
one of those weird things if anything
has just come up with storytelling the
the whole the whole idea behind this is
that when kang showed up he initially
faced off against the young avengers and
then the combined efforts of the young
avengers and the avengers themselves
during this point in time while kate
bishop was not a game changer she
basically demonstrated she was more than
enough to hold her own against someone
like kang who was largely considered to
be one of the most dangerous villains
the avengers have ever faced and
possibly even the most dangerous because
of his ability to control time and so
with with kate bishop demonstrating her
prowess as a fighter in a lot of ways
close to uh the capabilities of hawkeye
cassie lang being the daughter of
scotland having the ability to grow and
shrink all these different things and
ultimately the young avengers team was
fully formed now while the young
avengers line would be canceled the
reality was marvel didn't cancel it due
to low sales they canceled it because it
was actually smarter to relaunch it and
then actually cycle the young avengers
around through different stories that
were going on at the time to give them a
larger fan base try to kind of advertise
them and show people what they were
capable of and so on and so forth at the
end of the day the young avengers was
cool uh it wasn't the single most
popular story that marvel had published
but it did have some great stories going
on in it but with regards to uh to kate
bishop herself there were a few things
that went on but a lot of the stories
involving this focused more on the young
avengers than really just kate bishop
there were some character-based story
arcs that were going on right because
when you're basically dealing with a
bunch of teenage superheroes you're
going to run into the teenage superhero
element right that's been a mainstay of
comics since the old teen titans comics
over at dc but i will say that one of
the single biggest things as part of the
young avengers was the actual taking of
the hawkeye mantle by k bishop and a lot
of this happened because kate bishop
acted in a way that was very similar to
the way that clint barton would have
acted in terms of the idea that captain
america had kind of stood in the face of
the young avengers and said no you guys
aren't ready you guys don't need to be a
superhero team and kate bishop stood up
to him in the same way clint barton
would have and so because jessica jones
was kind of watching all this unfold in
her mind while kate bishop may not
necessarily have been on the same level
in terms of capabilities as clint barton
she was clint barton in virtually every
other facet of how she functioned and
what she could bring to the table and so
in reality it just made good sense that
she would take up the mantle of hawkeye
which she did and so going forward the
big question a lot of fans had is that
if kate bishop had previously idolized
clint barton albeit if only from a
distance but now she had essentially
taken on the mantle that was previously
given to clint and worse than that had
done it during the time in which he was
dead what would happen when the two of
them officially met now we covered this
to a degree in our original videos on
civil war but honestly we didn't go
super in depth into it and a lot of that
is because the first real encounter
between kate bishop as hawkeye and clint
barton who'd been brought back and
previously had been hawkeye didn't
really take place until the fallen sun
story arc now for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar fallen sun was a really
cool line of stories and it basically
dealt with the aftermath of the
assassination of captain america now the
idea was that at the time tony stark had
actually approached clint barton about
becoming captain america about taking up
the shield the costume the whole nine
yards kate bishop wasn't really on board
with it and that was kind of a big deal
because you would hope that when the two
of them first met that it would kind of
be one of these things where it's like i
give you my blessing you're pretty cool
yeah go ahead be hawkeye do your thing
instead it was it was him in a lot of
ways taking a front to the idea that she
had taken his mantle during the time in
which she was dead right so taking
offense to it and the fact that she saw
clint barton as taking over a role that
no one should take over right no one
should take over the mantle of captain
america especially if the mantle is
being offered to them by the person that
most superheroes at the time blamed for
the death of captain america anyway
which was tony stark that while tony
stark didn't necessarily pull the
trigger and in fact it wasn't really
even him who was controlling sharon
carter uh and ultimately led to her
shooting captain america a lot of people
saw the death of captain america as an
extension of the initial civil war event
which tony stark had caused and so in a
lot of ways there was a huge amount of
animosity towards tony tony stark and
kate bishop had seen tony stark's
actions in approaching anybody you know
with the and offering them the mantle of
captain america as a huge sign of
disrespect towards steve rogers now her
seeing clint barton do this was enough
that two of them had a conversation and
clint barton ultimately agreed and said
you know what i think you're right and
so the two of them found mutual ground
in their belief that captain america was
a mantle that had such a high honor that
it shouldn't just be arbitrarily given
away now as we know tony stark ended up
choosing bucky barnes to be the person
to become the new captain america but
this was significant for the
relationship between clint barton and
kate bishop because what it did is it
gave us what was in effect the future of
their characters that you saw some
things going on in between write secret
invasion siege different things like
that like a lot of these stories that
focus on the idea of the superhero
landscape being shifted in a few
different ways but the biggest change
particularly for kate bishop in her
relationship with clint barton as well
as just for kate bishop's development
herself came during children's crusade
now children's crusade was a colossal
story right up to this point in time it
was the biggest change for kate bishop
the children's crusade focused on an
explanation of one what the the young
avengers what their role is in the
larger marvel universe and two the
character of tommy and billy now tommy
and billy as most of you guys know are
the kids of scarlet witch at the time
when they first showed up we didn't know
we had no idea they were the kids let's
call it witch and in fact they had their
own lives right they had their own
parents the whole nine yards there was
no reason to believe they were in any
way tied into wanda maximoff we ended up
learning that they were but for kate
bishop this was a huge moment and the
reason why is because at the end of
children's crusade the young avengers
were officially sanctioned as a branch
off team from the avengers themselves
now the reason why this was so important
for kate bishop and by extension really
everybody else but the reason why it was
so important for kate bishop is because
it was the superhero community
officially recognizing that one she was
hawkeye and two what she could bring to
the table right officially getting that
mantle up until this point in time she
was in a lot of ways kind of a
reflection of how some fans saw her
which was a cast off i mean even if you
go back and you look at the old allen
heinberg stories she didn't want the
hawkeye mantle right she didn't want
that she took it grudgingly but she
didn't really want it in the same way
that carol danvers didn't really want
the captain marvel mantle during the
kelly sue deconic run and then
ultimately took it right so it's one of
these things where kate bishop had kind
of evolved and grown and become an
actual officially recognized member of
the avengers landscape following that
the adventures between her and clint
barton were awesome because in a lot of
ways it was really kind of like a
superhero and not really a sidekick but
really just kind of a dual superhero
team that as kate bishop served
alongside hawkeye her skills expanded
dramatically because she had clint
barton teaching her seemingly everything
she needed to know everything clint
barton knew about like spy work about
subterfuge espionage about how to use a
multitude of different weapons she was
by no means incompetent when she first
showed up but she was not clint barton
level ultimately she got to that point
now a lot of this came by way of what is
by many considered to be one of the most
celebrated hawkeye runs of all time
which was hawkeye vol 4 by matt fraction
this story was fantastic the funny thing
about this is matt fraction's hawkeye
run was kind of the story that came at
the right place at the right time if
we're being honest right by this point
in kate's history the stage had been set
right it was kind of like okay she's
fully recognized as being a member of
the avengers team clint barton is her
mentor he's the guy that's going to go
forward and teach her the kind of things
she needs to know to be every bit as
capable as him who's going to be the one
to handle it and the way that matt
fraction wrote this was fantastic
because in a lot of ways it was kind of
a buddy cop story right it was so cool
the way their adventures transpired and
the way they took place it's one of the
stories that i usually tell people they
should always go check out it was in a
lot of ways a kind of buddy cop slash
father-daughter mentor mentee kind of
relationship and it was cool one thing i
do want to clarify as far as i'm aware
there was never really anything in the
realm of impropriety i'm not really
familiar with clint barton and kate
bishop having had any kind of a romantic
involvement with each other just because
of how they saw each other right i mean
they saw each other as as like father
and daughter right so you know this is
not the ultimate universe
you know the stories as they were told
by matt fraction were great right they
were incredible character development
and i always tell people if you're ever
interested in getting into kate bishop
that's the story to read now because of
the success of matt fraction's run the
partnership between kate bishop and
clint barton became a mainstay for quite
some time and really this ran all the
way up to the events of all new hawkeye
volume two and this was significant
because what you had here was the first
real beginnings of a rift between the
two where i wouldn't say things were
perfect right you know it wasn't like
things were perfect and it was happily
ever after and it was nothing but laughs
and giggles right i mean there were
times where they had disagreements but
if anything it was kind of a partnership
disagreement right where the the general
understanding the mutual understanding
is yes we don't see eye to eye but at
the end of the day we're still good
friends we get along all that began to
change was something called project
communion now project communion was
given to us as this sort of project that
was launched by hydra that a lot of ways
was designed to be hydra's own version
of weapons plus right the projects that
gave birth to like captain america frank
simpson nuke wolverine but they actually
did it with kids and the way this worked
was that these kids were subjected to a
litany of experiments that gave them
powers that were not fully defined
ultimately they were taken by shield and
kate bishop knew as well as clint barton
that shield was going to end up using
them for nefarious purposes right they
were going to study them they were going
to examine them they were going to tell
them lies and then ultimately turn them
into shield agents kate bishop didn't
want them to have that instead she
wanted them to have as close to a normal
life as they possibly could have now a
lot of this went back to the early roots
of kate bishop when she was created by
alan heinberg the idea that she had
volunteered at soup kitchens she was
very much a kind of charitable person as
opposed to clint barton who wasn't
really a jerk so much as a person who
believed that what he was doing was
usually always the right thing to do and
so what ended up happening here is both
kate bishop and clint martin basically
busted the kids out from a shield
helicarrier and then took him back to
clint's place hydra caught up to them a
whole fight broke out the kids ended up
killing the hydra agents and then clint
barton basically responded by saying no
they need to be handed back over again
right like these kids are legitimate
weapons right they're dangerous because
of what happened because of clint's
response to this and and having such a
dramatic event take place in the life of
kate's uh of cater self they simply
couldn't find common ground on this and
so ultimately clint barton relented they
ended up rescuing the project communion
kids in the first place and while they
were able to mend ties to a degree their
relationship was never the same right
that clint martin was like look you're
my best friend everything's cool and
kate you know kind of responded by
saying well you're still my hero but at
the end of the day the writing was on
the wall it was only a matter of time
before the two of them began the or at
least the process started them going
their own separate ways because their
relationship was irrevocably changed it
was one of these instances when clint
barton just didn't trust the viewpoints
of kate bishop something that he had
done was seemingly the greatest of ease
up to that point but truth to tell by
this point in time right we were already
out of secret wars right we're already
out of secret wars from 2015 right
things are going forward you've already
got uh you know jeremy renner playing
hawkeye in in the the marvel cinematic
universe from avengers in 2012 and even
some of the movies leading up to that
point the honest truth here was that
because jeremy renner was hawkeye in the
mcu and during this point in time and
even now marvel comics really mimics the
mcu more than the mcu mimics marvel
comics we basically ended up seeing kate
bishop fall to the background right fall
to the wayside she wasn't ignored
entirely she had some interesting
stories right when like old man logan
wolverine from an alternate reality
ended up showing up in the main marvel
universe that kate bishop was one of the
people that kind of helped to bring him
back and help him realize he's not
actually in his own universe he's not in
the past of his own universe he's in a
wholly different universe now but by and
large she was a background character
right she was just kind of a character
off doing her own thing in more recent
years with hawkeye by by kelly thompson
she's taken up a kind of investigative
mantle on her own but again there hasn't
really been a whole lot from her
character in terms of her kind of
returning to what was in effect the more
prominent version of herself that we'd
seen during the days of the young
avengers and especially during matt
fraction's run now to be honest with you
guys that's probably going to change now
that she's got a tv show but we won't
really know until we find out how the tv
show ends that by all standards of
measurement from what we can tell it
looks like clint barton is going to take
a background he might might even retire
but we also know that coming out of the
black widow movie that the sister of
natasha romanoff is now being set on
course to basically track down clint
barton so whether he'll be gone forever
we don't really know we don't know if
kate bishop is going to be his first
attempt to train somebody new kate
bishop dies at the end of like the
hawkeye series so he turns to his
daughter and she ends up becoming like
the new hawkeye we don't really know
what form this is going to take well i
kind of will have to wait till the show
comes out to get a better idea of it if
i'm a betting man marvel's setting the
stage for the new slash young avengers
kate bishop's gonna do fine she's gonna
survive to the end of it she's gonna go
on into the marvel cinematic universe
movies right the tv shows are basically
just being used to set the stage for
like the next set of mcu movies and
they'll just follow that pattern using
shows to set the stage for movies and
just kind of going from there uh but
again you know at this point not a whole
lot going on with kate bishop and there
really hasn't been for quite some time
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace